تم إغلاق المطار في باليرمو صقلية
لعدة ساعات عندما اقتربت الحرائق بشكل
مرعب من مدارج الطائرات هناك،
ألقِ نظرة على هذا، وقد
أعيد فتحه الآن في هذه الأثناء في الجزائر، يكافح أكثر من
7000 رجل إطفاء حوالي
مائة حريق غابات وسط درجات حرارة
تصل إلى 48 درجة مئوية في  قُتل 34 شخصًا على الأقل،
من بينهم 10 جنود
كانوا يساعدون في القتال، ونحن على
وشك أن نعرض لكم مقطع فيديو مزعجًا
من مأساة مماثلة في اليونان والتي
تعاني أيضًا من حرائق الغابات. هنا
يمكنك رؤية طائرة إطفاء
تحطمت أثناء إغراقها  أفادت التقارير أن
شخصين كانا على متن السفينة بسبب المياه في جزيرة إيفيا،
وحذر رئيس الوزراء اليوناني من أن الحرائق والحرارة
من المتوقع أن تتفاقم وليس
تتحسن مع استمرار ظروف الجفاف،
وقد انضمت جزيرة كريت الآن إلى الطرق
وكورفو تحت خطر شديد من حرائق الغابات.